I promise it'll be fast Ilan Bob shirt
guy from Thomson Reuters India just
launched a mission to Mars 75 million
dollars to get that thing was it as
Astro teller said a miracle or is there
something fundamental about the Indian
space industry that allowed them to do a
mission like that for so cheap and if so
is there something that we can pick up
and learn from that I think it's a very
impressive mission given that it was
executed by a government entity it's
like really really impressive
I mean impressive no matter who's doing
it but from a cost standpoint impressive
because it's being done by a government
entity ultimately we have to be able to
do missions to Mars for much less than
that otherwise it'll be impossible to
establish a self-sustaining civilization
on Mars because we'll have to transport
millions of tons of cargo planes to
people and the cost of moving to Mars
has to be affordable otherwise people
won't be able to go so it has to
ultimately come down by couple resumed
attitude from from that level a couple
orders magnitude I say blow well below a
million yeah